bonjour younès belle fait la merci de
répondre à nos questions à quoi
s'attendre aujourd'hui en terme de
participation parce que beaucoup
d'observateurs parlent d'un scrutin sans
illusion ni espoir une partie de
l'opposition a même appelé au boycott
oui tout à fait en fait il s'agit en
fait des élections qui vient dans un
cadre qui est un petit peu compliqué
pour le pour le pays c'est d'abord une
réponse à des manifestations qu'a connu
le pays depuis 2000 2010 a fait un
mouvement de contestation qui est
demandé la déchéance on va dire de toute
la classe toute la classe politique et
surtout le lien entre l'irak et l
influence iranienne dans ceux dans ce
pays qui en fait qu'ils trouvent un
terrain de jeu très important du fait
que la majorité des habitants de layrac
sens d dans le sang des chics et donc
avec une présence bien sûr très très
forte des des milices donc des milices
qui sont bien armés et que représente en
quelque sorte e année à parallèle et
avec avec une forte présence ont ce qui
concerne l'aspect politique militaire ou
même aussi même aussi économique donc
l'enjeu pour le premier ministre irakien
actuellement c'est de réussir des
élections de montrer d'abord la capacité
de pays de gérer des élections dans un
cadre de sécurité et bien évidemment
poser un grand problème pour répondre à
toutes les questions et toutes les
problématiques économiques il s'impose
surtout la question du chômage dans un
pays aux eaux dans
65% de la population sont des sondés
sont des jeunes bien sûr ça jetons à
cela toutes les enjeux on va dire
géopolitique de ce pays qui représente
un carrefour très intéressant de
géopolitique entre l'influencé
américaine l'influencé iranienne la
relation avec le monde arabe et surtout
aussi là là on va dire la la la la
division de ce pays qui était organisé
en quelque sorte par la constitution de
paul bremer m'envoyer américain en 2000
en 2004 qui a donné le premier ou le pot
le poste de premier ministre
haché it le poste de chef de parlement à
un sioniste est également à donner une
certaine autonomie pour l'épauler kurdes
qui ont vraiment à une autonomie très
très intéressante très fort dans le pays
et qui représente également un autre
dans tout ça à quoi aspirent les
irakiens on l'a dit qu'ils étaient très
nombreux à protester il y a deux ans
d'abord la lutte contre la corruption
parce qu'il faut rappeler quand même que
l'irak a connu comme m des vagues de
corruption très intéressante en parle
quand même de 2000 milliards de dollars
de dépenses et de vaud qui ont été volés
dans ce pays pendant les dix dernières
li dernières années deuxièmement la
question économico sociale qui est ligne
et à
allah le pouvoir d'achat et la question
du chômage et troisièmement un enjeu que
je trouve très intéressant pour ce pays
c'est la question aussi de la sécurité
il faut rappeler que toutes les
organisations terroristes est
principalement l'état islamique a trouvé
un terrain de jeu très intéressant en
irak et la même crié à certains moments
d i d i désignera on va dire islamiste
dans le pays surtout dans la partie du
dumont au sol et donc ce qui a fait en
quelque sorte le besoin pour l'irak
d'appeler des forces internationales
d'intervenir dans ce cadre donc là
maintenant on va dire le risque de
terrorisme il est toujours
omniprésent vu ce qui se passe tout
simplement en afghanistan pour bien
comprendre que cette région elle est
toujours poudrière de mouvement
terroriste est ce que de nouvelles
manifestations post électorales et des
débordements sont à craindre et si oui
de quelle ampleur
oui tout à fait va toujours y a il ya
toujours les besoins les manifestations
les réclamations va dire qu'ils ont été
déclarés en 2010 900 toujours présente
aujourd'hui maintenant je trouve que le
les élections vont présenter assise
politique très important pour le pur
pour le pays il reste bien évidemment à
présenter un programme du gouvernement
capable de convaincre surtout les élus
les jeunes et de leur présenter des
solutions ad à des problèmes des
problématiques on va dire
quotidiennement au niveau des relations
internationales on constate qui est
quand même un routeur de l'irak à la
scène arabe le fait de faire des
relations avec les pays du golfe on la
remarque aussi dès l'ouverture à
d'autres pays comme la turquie comme la
russie et comme la france qui a organisé
une conférence ça fait plus de deux mois
avec avec avec l'irak et qui rentre en
quelque sorte une nouvelle page dans
l'histoire on va dire de miracle ce que
le pays a besoin de seuil et de ses
forces internationales afin de
reconstruire son pays sur soudan en
matière de projets d'infrastructures
merci une asbl félin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en relations internationales
spécialiste du monde arabe